nerd wars time it's Friday again we're
gonna do some old-school action today Oh
nerd wars someone suggested this on the
YouTube channel comment you know that
thing down here and I was too lazy to
figure out who it was I we forgot but
here it is link versus Mario I'm gonna
be doing link I'm gonna be doing mark
that sounds yeah it does sound dirty
hello I'm gonna be doing the little boy
with the pony hat I'm going to be
arguing in favor of the Italian plumber
good its didn't wanna start off kicking
off I'll start it off alright uh okay
I'm gonna talk inventory alright
mario has the inventory he has he has an
out inventory oh come on he's got it
he's got a backpack that shoots water
he's got he grabs a star he's invincible
he shooting fireballs he's got he's got
a raccoon suit a cuicci suit a friggin
dead I reckon you don't even know wrong
he's got a frog suit okay so you're
gonna get a frog he can turn into a frog
can turn it was Virginie skills but he
has no weapon skills but the water
cannon slightly okay fireballs Lincoln
just bounce them off of the shield Bing
Bing Bing Bing
then just knife him Oh a little freaking
furry tail shield shank shield shank
you're done yeah and we're done of
course oh meringue Mario would just okay
I beat enough hammer brothers in Mario
games to know you can just jump over
that boomer I can't Ange I'm for shame
right on Lynx head they can't aim for
and then aim for nothing you can
throw the boomerang and then you could
just knife the guy when you came too
close no yes no what I mean what else
you got oh okay well doesn't have the
power the Triforce the link doesn't have
any power whatsoever League magical
power Blin Triforce is sniveling a
little Oh hold on here you're
talking that the guy who cleans drains
for a living is going to defeat a hero
that's his whole purpose is to be hero
no the thing is Mario you think that
shield would stop him Mario would just
go down a tunnel to go down a pipe flute
pop right up behind them fireball
freak but no crime tunnel there's
tunnels too there's tunnels in Mario I
decide to use a pipe at the bottom of
pipes hmm I could also go into a snake
barrel if it's my brother - let's talk
about pack up Posse link has no backup
Posse we're not talking about
where's his Yoshi fairies fairies all
right
link hangs out with a bunch of fairies
that's all he's got Mario has got his
brother
all right Luigi he's got Yoshi he's got
Princess Toadstool which just proves how
lame Mario is he needs this backup Posse
where's up link can just go strength in
numbers
Lincoln be on his own and just save the
world third reason Mario I'd like to see
Mario pull the sword he could pull a
sword he can't pull the sword up he
could pull his own camp if he can pull
the daikon raddish not handled around
her sword if he can pull the daikon
radishes out of the ground in Mario
Brothers 2 he can pull a sword link
pulls up bushes Shh anybody could do
that pushes out any ground
Mario lifts all sorts of people right
above his head just throws and links a
stone-cold killer link is not a stone
cold have you seen how he like just
burns bushes down breaks people taught a
to the carapace is rude he's rude he's
an independent thinker all right
independent thinker mario has the
ability to grow facial hair while link
is prepubescent I can drone up yeah link
links grow narrow game link links grown
up in several games he grows up into a
taller little boy he never looks like a
man you know why cuz he doesn't a damn
man call me web link call me out mute
you doesn't need to be a man to defeat
Mario yet you do need to be Amanda
Bartoli's like a 7 year old
he's a 7 year old plumber Mario is
probably in like his mid-30s no he's way
older than that
yeah if you look the way think he's
wearing a head all the time look I know
at Mario my guy who knows he's not bald
balding that's no that's not why where's
the hell don't you take off with a hat
to Luigi he he wears the Hat because
underneath that he has all of his hair
he has a flowing mane he's like Fabio
he's like an Italian Fabio cuz I don't
think it's Fabio's Italian so it's a lot
more is just two company I'm gonna I'm
gonna give this one to link you're gonna
give it to Lake just because that's what
you want to say you're talking because
he's got weapon selection more mario has
tongue doesn't need a backup crew oh he
doesn't need no crew to kill people was
up yeah I'm sure he doesn't need a croak
but mario has a crew tomorrow would win
all right
we're gonna end this no we're not we're
gonna end it with me winning I win no
one ever why's this is the one that Adam
wins
Adam totally wins this one no no okay um
seriously
he lost his glasses again uh winner
widow K will give her
will say he's the winner post your
suggestions down below and we will we
will do them winner
[Music]
Oh
you